James: Another favourite squared square
Well it's this one
I say it's favourite because
This one was actually found before the Trinity students found theirs
They were scooped
It was just before them
And this was published first, and that's so disappointing.
So, if I'm being technical this was the first squared square found.
But, there's no theory behind it
Brady: It was just some fluke or --
J: It was some fluke, yeah
It's made out of squared rectangles
It was actually those previous squared rectangles that had been found
There's copies of those in there
He's put them together and scaled them up and scaled them down
There's no maths in that, it doesn't help you find more...
It tells you no theory about it.
B: It's the first though
J: But it was the first.
That is so annoying as well
Here's one more square
And this, this one I like because it's more
Aesthetically pleasing
Notice the squares are more 'round about the same size
So instead of having a squared square were you have one tiny square, one massive square
Which, a lot of them seem to look like that
This one's more balanced
The squares are around about the same size
If they take the ratio of the biggest to the smallest
This has the kindest ratio
This is the more favourable ratio
B: The kindest one?
J: I don't know, maybe
It's called a nice squared square
It's the smallest ratio between the biggest and smallest
B: It's like you, James, a nice square
J: Yeah, I like to think so
One thing that's tempting to do with these squared squares is to turn them into puzzles
'Cause you can cut them up and say can you make them into a square or something like that
This is actually a rectangle
This is a rectangle that I've made out of the smaller squares
I must find the complete set
I think some of the smaller ones are still in here
B: Yeah, having missing ones is no good
J: There you go
So it's like a jigsaw
Can you put these together like a jigsaw?
And, so that's what one of the Trinity students did
He actually
This is the one he turned into a puzzle
And he gave it to his mum
And he said, "Well, I know what the solution is, but can you find it?"
And so, she tried to find the solution
And it turned out that she found a different solution
Using the same squares
B: No?
J: So there are two ways
To use the same squares
To make a rectangle
Of the same dimension as well
So the same dimension
And that's nice
So those are called isomers
So they are two rectangles, the same dimension, using the same squares
But in a different order
Okay
I'm gonna say it
This was Bill Tutte's training in maths
Bill Tutte was given problems at Bletchley Park
Because they knew he liked puzzles
They knew was the kind of a guy who liked to do a problem [as] a puzzle
And they gave him problems that they thought couldn't be solved
And they thought, "Oh, we've given up on this
"Here you go and do it"
And so he worked away
And people were kind of looking over going,
"Is he actually doing anything? 'Cause he doesn't seem to be doing anything"
But he was
And he solved these massively important problems
That helped us break codes in World War II
[SUBS: Caleb Shircliff]